- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is...
- Change lives.
Over to you, Tim Tebow.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- For me and playing sports,
it's not being focused on
winning or losing a game
because, yeah, you want to be the best.
You want to try to win Super Bowls
or make it to the Big
Leagues and all these things,
but you want to, at the end of the day,
be more than just the sport
you're trying to play.
You want to transcend that sport.
If all you do, if all I ever
did was win or lose at a game,
I don't really look at my
life as a lot of significance.
But if I can transcend that
sport to inspire people,
to put a smile on people's
faces, to encourage people,
to make a difference,
to change one person's life
or a million people's lives,
then I would consider that
significance and meaning.
The goal is not to be famous.
The goal is not to have
money in your bank account.
The goal is not to have what
the world defines as a success.
The goal is to change lives.
- So what do you think?
- I think it resonates true,
where you're trying to do,
in whatever position you do,
whether you're doing
something socially or at work
that you want to see people
around you that look up to you,
that you inspire, and
take them over the wing
and never be too tired
to give them more advice,
be there for them a little more.
To move away from your
selfishness, you know,
"I'm having a bad day" or
"I need to get this done"
and be there for pretty much
your team and your
friends and your family.
- Yeah, I think people get into things
often for the wrong reason.
I think a lot of people
start a YouTube channel
'cause they want to be YouTube famous
and they're only trying to
get a million subscribers.
I think a lot of people start a business
just trying to get rich.
They look at the Forbes magazine
or the Top 100 Hot Companies
To Start Right Now,
make a lot of money, and
then they get into it
and they realize it's a lot harder
than they thought it was going to be.
You have to enjoy the process.
You have to enjoy the work.
The people who win are on a mission.
They want to make the
world better somehow,
whether that's through
your YouTube channel,
through your business,
through your salsa dancing,
whatever it is,
you're on a mission that is much more
than just achieving the end result.
If you're only chasing result,
you're never going to get there,
but if you're enjoying the process,
then success will be yours.
So the question of the day today is...
- Have you been there
for someone else today?
I like it.
Leave it in the comments below
and we will join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Leong Sai Mun.
I hope I pronounce it okay.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really, really, really appreciate it
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you, guys, so much for watching.
We believe in you
and hope you continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
And we'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another...
- Shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(typewriter typing)
- I think in general you really should try
to live your life without regrets
and if you are really set on
starting a particular company,
even if you know that you could go
be employee number 30 at Airbnb
and Airbnb's already going like this,
and you'd have more of an impact,
but if you're going to regret
for the rest of your life
not starting this particular company
'cause you're so in love with it,
you might decide to do that.
However, I think this other thing,
like making an impact on whatever you do
is sort of the satisfying thing in life,
in professional life,
and so I think most people find
that their job satisfaction
like goes up with the impact they have
on their company or the world or whatever.
And if you start a company that is,
you know, a mild success
or join a company that's a huge success,
you probably have more of an
impact in the latter case.
- The thing which attracted me to Google
and to internet in general
is that it's a great equalizer, right?
And so to me, always
being struck by the fact
that Google search work the same
as long as you had access to
computer with connectivity,
if you were a rural kid anywhere
or if you were a professor
at Stanford or Harvard.
And to me, I want Google to
strive to push to do that,
not just build technology
for a certain segment.
For me, it matters that
we drive technology
as an equalizing force,
as an enabler to everyone
around the world.